we player on it seems every week home
where how do you get the job
Matt Lawrence is the latest cause like
new I try for UFC tonight my first time
I swear it's so nerve-wracking matches
last what happened in 30 minutes if
you'd like
what happened me with UFC tonight and my
whole everyone blacks is there Lauren my
whole squad is there and that you do
like so they do though they do theirs
and then they bring in people they want
to try out and I go in and just happen
be that car that weekend was all foreign
Brazilian Russians and you know I
struggle with Nate oh they don't tell
you what you're gonna go over so I'm
like what and there you go they go do
you know do you know the door on my hip
they go do you know the card this week
on it yeah yeah then when it's in Brazil
so you know the whole car do ya know the
card it's me in jail
you know chills but I love jumping
chillin it's totally yeah and so it's me
in jail talking and the names I'm like I
see my scream like oh god am i dying I
knew it didn't go well because you get
into it I went the toughest dude I went
I'll see you around
[ __ ] it not for me I just get worse and
worse let me hear I don't know if you
couldn't let me do what had a player
honored on the Associated Press this is
so funny my problem is I didn't have to
audition something to get on there like
but I'll be honest man they took well I
don't know what network this is but like
when I first started doing analyst work
with ESPN they didn't you know like the
UFC was I go shop can talk bring Saban
and it was a huge like it was ver doom
versus Cain Velasquez and Mark Hunt
verse I forget there's a huge car yeah
they had me there the whole weekend yeah
no one went over anything now is me know
I got to Bristol they gave me a tour of
yes
which I grew up watching and I'm like
holy [ __ ] the idea of your suit I'm like
yep gave it to the stylist they [ __ ]
steamed it put on makeup and then like
stage seven to the ramen what now they
yeah you're up like where's the produce
what are we
ere peace Mike but uh boom that's I know
I'm ESPN SportsCenter with J Crawford is
it guy right we got bread and job here
from lunch like dude what don't know we
didn't goes guys anything so good that's
so quick yeah let's remember the first
time you saw me box
you saw me the first time when Tony
Jefferies I was in with that Korean kid
big kid who hit really hard and he
wasn't box for either he's why I was I
stopped breathing because I got hit in
the face lit I wasn't wearing a bar and
I was like I don't I love and I stopped
breathing and I couldn't go on like he
I'd there were 30 seconds like I was
just too tired you just said I didn't
know I I just hadn't done it so I just
didn't know how to breathe and I was and
that happens to everybody that the
minute weird yeah we had this triathlete
it come into the gym really good athlete
try Africa yeah but he that never
sparked he got in he was just trying to
move around he just don't some somebody
was throwing punches not hitting him he
stopped breathing and he about 2 and 1/2
minutes if anything like that I think my
thing is on TV though like he had to
audition young it's a college thing he
was divas in the college thing and his
kid yeah it's a poor kid have you ever
ate [ __ ] with sure onset not onset but
certainly that it's like a snowball
effect like I've been bad I've been I've
eaten [ __ ] in auditions for big people
and important jobs when I was younger
I've just been terrible yeah Oh terrible
prepared I had to be no I had to be I to
do law and order like one time and like
when you go on for those people in New
York they get the best actors ever and I
get in there and I have to be I have to
be crazy and in love with my dolls and I
yeah and I and I was I was looking at my
dolls going near my babies I love you
guy and I was so bad and I was like
thank you like
you when you have to be crazy but you
can't do it you're not you're acting it
and you know how bad you are I was like
I'll never go back in there for them
again and I'll so I'm a terrible actor
and also I'm gonna quit I'm gonna quit
have your bill onstage and you know you
skipped like a key tag or shrine in the
shore but I've also been also like I'm
like I I'll find it down like I know
it's weird because I'll be going through
the bit on oh you mean like young yeah
I'm like oh I missed I missed that beat
well I'm gonna try fitnah don't like it
you're going through it as you're
talking and you're like I'm gonna put it
here I wants to put it over sure it's so
strange I've repeated a joke once
because you do to show sometimes no no
no wait I just yeah that's right so when
I was like yeah did I already yeah did I
come out with this now the worst is when
you do a dramatic play which I've done
and I got a full house and I just can't
feel it or find it and I have to be in
and you're like I'm gonna have to act my
way through this and be absolutely
terrible that kind of [ __ ] I went
through a lot of that acting wise
because some pieces some material you
can't you can't do the piece without
having it you have to hate your father
in the piece or you don't have a play
you have to you have to be on drugs you
have to be drunk whatever it is if
you're not it's going to be a very long
night though Morgan is like it's the
longest night you're gonna feel the
audience move around and Lee is just
terrible and that's what makes you work
hard because you're like I can't be
really bad I'm gonna be yeah okay this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]